well we are outside westminster abbey
where a service of thanksgiving and
memorial service for uh prince philip
has taken place and one of those who was
inside is richard griffin a former royal
personal protection officer who worked
both for the duke of edinburgh and the
queen and i'm delighted to say that he
joins me now outside and richard how was
the service and and did you think it was
a a good reflection of the duke's life
it was it was a wonderful service i mean
obviously the highlight for everyone was
seeing a majesty the queen arrived but
then seeing so many people that have
worked with prince for their polish
charities
all the staff he's worked with over the
years and of course the address as well
was absolutely wonderful it's some
prince phillip perfectly yes it can be
abrupt but what a wonderful man he was i
was going to say do you think he got his
essence absolutely had him spot on yes
how was the queen obviously there was a
lot of speculation she may not be able
to attend because of mobility we saw her
being escorted in um
what did you think when you saw her
i've seen the queen there
everywhere where i was we couldn't quite
see where the queen was sat but
fortunately over television screens that
we could see her take her place
and that was just so wonderful i mean it
was such a relief because we hear all
this thing in the press about if you
want to be well
so to see the queen come in and sit with
all the family that was wonderful
it was an emotional service it was very
emotional i mean i worked for prince
philip for 14 years and traveled the
world with him so did a lot of things
with him and obviously
deeply missed him when he died so it was
fantastic to be able to come today and
pay our respects
what was he like as a man what was he
like to work for
it was he was an absolute blessing he
can be erupt could be abrupt he could be
rude but he was the most caring man you
could possibly meet i'll give you a
couple of examples um
my son when he was 16 i had cancer
prince philip
not only made sure i had enough time off
work
he ran the hospital checking on my son
regularly he ran my wife up ran the most
wrote the most beautiful letter to her
and the same in my daughter once she was
working in a hotel in scotland couldn't
get back for christmas
and unknown to me prince philip was up
at balmoral giving christmas presents
out to the staff
and he arranged for the staff to go and
collect my daughter and he flew her back
to london so she could spend christmas
with me that's prince philip
what do you think he'd have thought of
the service today
i'm sure listening to the
hymns which i knew he loved prince
philip had a big footprint in that
service today
you could see it right the way through
and they're hard for for those who
wanted to marcus passing last year
because of covert it's true i can't
believe it no it's you're doing really
well
very hard for people who weren't able to
attend the funeral last year because of
kovid you know like so many people
the fact that this service
although it's a year later
had contained a lot of things that he
would have wanted didn't it absolutely i
mean all these charities that were
represented there today um as i said all
these staff were there um
it was just a wonderful wonderful
service it was great for us all to be a
pair of respects to him
what about the younger royals do you
think they have the same
sense of dedication perhaps that prince
philip had yes i do i mean don't forget
principal it was their grandfather so
williams and tom's had a great training
from and he's going to learn all these
examples from him
um
fingers crossed to just hope harry
collects and gets some of these things
into his mind
well he's not here today obviously and
there has been quite a lot of
disappointment for everybody weren't
people talking about that yes they were
what were they saying
certainly rome were either they thought
you should have been here you know and
all this nonsense about
um he couldn't get protection you know
as i'm concerned that was a pathetic
excuse he should have been here to honor
his grandfather
there is certainly a great deal of
security here today isn't there so there
wouldn't have been any question about
that
at the end of the day
if he was that worried about security he
could have stuck with his brother and
his father who've got wonderful security
and he'd been more more than safe
what about you you mentioned the the the
singing and the hymns that were sang
today but also i've just noticed in your
tie you've got dark green in it a lot of
the other members of the congregation
were also around a very dark green
is that a coincidence or or is there a
reason for that this this tie here is a
tied prince philip designed
so anyone who works in this personal
household this this is the tie that they
all wore
so that was the dark green was the
colour of his household absolutely and
as designed by prince phillip
so obviously when this service came out
we've all been quickly going through our
wardrobes trying to find this tie
and that may explain why a lot of the
ladies are wearing the very dark dark
green as well oh that's great well i'm
glad you've been able to clear that up
for us
and
you know you've given so much of your
life to the royal family these events
must must for you mark the end of an era
as well
don't they because
when will you next see these people
well hopefully um
that's a good question actually
i'm still playing golf at windsor castle
so we still see a majesty around there
and we still exchange christmas cards
but no you're right i mean i don't no
one knows the answer to that
well richard griffin former oil
protection officer thank you so much for
coming down today and sharing your
thoughts about the service it's really
lovely to talk to you